ciao sono nato coscienza ciao sondato
coscienza che giorno è oggi
no non è il 32 di agosto cretina oggi
primo settembre l'estate ufficialmente
finita purtroppo ebbene sì oh mio dio
l'estate è finita ragazze oggi il primo
settembre e del jornal do dicevo oggi
primo settembre la giornata ufficiale
degli inizi dei buoni propositi degli
inizi della fine
iniziamo subito con una breve lista dei
buoni propositi che ci sono tre fatti
così sembrano sei sono tre al numero uno
il buono proposito al numero uno c'è
sicuramente la dieta quindi dimagrire e
mangiare sano andare a fare è sporta nei
90 settimane che l'etichetta wow
perché noi ci crediamo noi ci
focalizziamo mettiamo posti di tutta la
casa e dieta da oggi e dieta melo sono
ripromessa oggi abbiamo settembre però a
venerdì si potenzia lunedì in mano
comunque previste e poi dopo due secondi
che abbiamo nel baratro della vita alla
numero 2 c'è ovviamente l'università o
la scuola quindi per chi di voi va
ancora a scuola c'è ovviamente la voglia
magari di arrivare a fine anno senza
debiti quest'anno che dida ce la
possiamo fare è certo questo è il
proposito proprio più bello di tutti ma
per chi vola università invece c'è la
gioia di passare almeno un esame di
riuscire a laurearsi in tempo
ecco vi sono vicino ci sono passato
anch'io era bellissimo all'università
poi arrivava la sessione estiva dare
qualche esame magari a giugno ne poi
quelli di luglio insomma ecco ma vi darò
settembre
troppi ricordi e è la numero 3 come
sempre arriva l'amore e speriamo che dio
ce la mandi sano di mente stavolta vabbè
poi oltre sano di mente anche applicate
o in tour i geni che è servita vinifica
che si parlano di te e ti piacciono i
genitori dove imparano finalmente il 90
per cento degli italiani soffre di
sindrome da buoni propositi nessuno di
lui porta a compimento questi buoni
propositi è una piaga forte una piaga
che va combattuta chiamate subito il
numero verde 800 894 66
sosteniamo anche lui una persona che non
porterà avanti i buoni propositi del
primo set
se vi è piaciuto al video ragazzi
ricordatevi di lasciare un piccolo
commento di mettere like se non siete
ancora iscritti al mio canale
iscrivetevi assolutamente e seguitemi
sugli altri social instagram musicali e
un bacione a dolo
[Musica]
vento